bürgermeister was verbinden sie mit dem
nationalfeiertag der nationalfeiertag in
österreich hat seinen ursprung am 26
oktober 1955 wird im parlament
immerwährende neutralität beschlossen
und schutz für diese immer während der
neutralität ist unter anderem deshalb
wichtig nicht nur für die militärische
landesverteidigung sondern für viele
katastropheneinsätze und ich bin gerade
ist wie der bürgermeister dem bundesheer
sehr dankbar denn es war in der
vergangenheit oft notwendig dass bei den
verschiedensten was ist wenn es ein
finsterer seite steht und dafür ein
herzliches dankeschön und der
nationalfeiertag reuter ist eine gute
gelegenheit sich bei den mitgliedern die
lösung in lucia zu bedanken und zeigt
aber auch die starke resonanz